welcome everyone from
around the world thank you for joining
us for today's presentation
entitled cancer transcriptome atlas with
ngs readout the essential tool for
spatial genomics
in oncology and it's my real pleasure to
introduce you to kit
furman he's the geomics rna product
manager at nanostring technologies
and for a complete biography of kit and
all our speakers you can visit the tab
at the bottom of your screen now if you
have any questions during the
presentation
please submit them in the q a box below
and our speaker will respond
back to you via email so please join me
in welcoming kit
and i'll turn the presentation over to
him
hello thank you for joining my name is
kip vernon i am the product manager for
the geomex rna
assays today i would like to introduce
our cancer transcriptome atlas
which is an essential tool for spatial
genomics and oncology research
so genomics research has evolved quite
considerably over the last 15 years
bulk gene expression has taught us much
about tumor biology
just like that fruit smoothie on the
left we've had to homogenize the tissue
for this to work
even so these gene expression signatures
has taught us a lot
about the state of the tumor about how
it's inflamed
um and how can we we can inform
different
uh decisions so the next iteration
was single cell biology where we're able
to pick apart and figure out
all the different pieces of fruit that
went into the fruit smoothing
we can discern different cell types and
different phenotypes and functionality
in these cells but putting it back
together
is where we struggle right now putting
it back in the original framework and
the original architecture of the tissue
is a very difficult task this is where
the power of the digital spatial
profiler
comes into play it allows the user to
see the spatial landscape
and quantify expression across important
regions of interest
today we are introducing the cancer
transcriptomatilis or what we call the
cta
combined with the ngs readout for the
geomets dsp platform
the cta is the first genomics assay to
leverage the almost unlimited plex of
our new ngs readout chemistry
we've built reagent probes sets that
allow
an almost limited number of targets to
be quantified simultaneously
with the cta you can measure 1834
different mrna gene transcripts
throughout the tumor
immune system and the micro environment
importantly our technology is not
limited by high expressos
dsp enriches for transcripts that are
critical to your research
regardless of expression levels and you
can
map these gene expression values
directly
to regions within your tissue
so when designing this probe set we
began by adding in all the important
immune targets
the immune system plays a critical role
in oncology and in many other diseases
so we included genes involved in innate
and adaptive immune systems
any researcher studying the immune
system whether infectious disease
or oncology will find these targets
informative
we also layered in targets from our key
encounter panels including the pan
cancer pathways and io 360 panels
we added clinically relevant gene sets
um and we added in uh metabolic genes
um there are considerable number of
metabolic gene targets in this panel
and it allows the researcher to study
the metabolic state of the
tumor and the immune system
importantly we also added in a lot of
information and gene targets through
community
input we mine both the literature
and other presentations and online gene
sets in databases
to make sure that all the important
informative targets were in this panel
finally we fully annotated the probe set
this allows the user to bring context to
every gene
in this atlas the cta includes genes to
identify critical immune cell types such
as t cells and macrophage subsets
we've also added gene sets that offer
insight into immune biology such as the
tumor information set
and the pam 50 gene signatures
the cancer transcript atlas encompasses
over 95
different biological pathways and has
many annotations built in
having all this great content in one
place is made possible by our unique
chemistry
our probes hybridize directly to
transcripts within
the formally fixed parameter tissue
section or your fresh frozen tissue
section
the readout portion which we call the
dsp barcode
contains a readout tag sequence for
every target and
a unique molecular identifier for every
molecule
we also included the truseq primary
regions to make the readout compatible
with an illumina sequencer
the photocleavable linker between the
probe and the readout portion is a key
part of the dsp platform
we use uv light to collect the dsp
barcode
for downstream analysis for specific
regions of interest
any project begins with staining a
tissue section with the cancer
transcriptome atlas probes
and a set of up to four morphological
markers including a dna stape
this is step one the morphology markers
can either be
antibodies with fluorescent labels or
rna scope probes to visualize individual
transcripts
the markers allow us to visualize the
tissue sections
and guides the region of interest or roi
selections
this is step two
so i would like to take a moment just to
talk about the rna scope probes that
we've integrated into
the geometry flow visualizing and
understanding the landscape of favorite
tissue is critical to connecting the
genomics information
to spatial context rna scope is
integrated is an integrated tool
to visualize single transcripts
you can visualize the three different
transcripts and you can choose from our
list of predefined rna scope
virtual kits or you can build your own
combination
rna scope is a unique tool for selecting
regions and often times
difficult to target gene targets such as
tgf beta and box b3
so i'd like to give you an example of
how we go about selecting regions of
interest
here we have non-small cell lung
carcinoma tissue section
and it's been stained with four
morphological markers
dna cd3
pdcd1 which is the transcript for pd-1
and cd-274 which is the transcript for
pdl1
so these are immune checkpoint genes and
so we've
scanned the whole tissue section and
then we've zoomed in
and selected individual regions of
interest
we've used our morphology stain to
select three different region types
across the whole tissue so multiple
regions of the same type
um on the top you can see that we've
selected regions that are high for pdc1
and the stroma
and then regions below which are in the
tumor which are
low for pd1 and then on the right we've
selected tumor regions that are high for
pd1 so
in this way we can categorize the
different regions
um that we're selecting
dsp importantly allows us to study the
transcriptional
profile of each of these regions
independently
so now that we've stained our tissue and
selected the regions of interest
the machine will then illuminate every
single
region it will the barcodes and dsp
barcodes
will come off of the tissue they will be
collected by the instrument
and deposited in a well in a 96 well
collection plate this process is then
repeated for steps three and four for
every single
uh region that the user has selected at
the
at this point the clutch plate is then
processed in our library prep
and sequenced on the luminous sequencer
now that each region is one well in our
collection plate
we can take it and process the dsb
barcodes
nanostring provides all the reagents you
need to
perform the library prep then once it's
sequenced
we provide all the tools needed to take
the data
from fast q files to analyzing the data
to construct the library prep management
has developed the geometry c
code reagent to process and collect the
dsp barcode logos
from the cta assay we've built an eight
plate set of
universal dual index adapters these
indices are properly color balanced
indices so that you can process these
barcodes in the order they are collected
no need to cherry pick wells
then the system will will actually
identify which
how to set up the library prep we use
the dual indices to map the dc
barcodes from the illuminated regions to
the resulting genomic cta gene
expression data
we also provide the pcr enzymes with the
seek code
along with the well specific primers the
pcr has the p5 and p7 regions
to the library constructs once the
library is generated you can pull all of
the wells together and run them on an
aluminum sequencer
you can multiplex a minimum of four
wells or all
768 wells from all eight unique plates
the seco library prep are compatible
across a wide range of illumina
sequencers
the number of reads needed depends on
the size of the region selected
for a typical region that is between two
to three million reads
for each slide with the typical number
of regions between 12 or 24 regions
you'd want to plan for 30 to 50 million
reads
only single end reads are needed but you
could certainly run the library with
paired and reads if you'd like
once the library has been sequenced
manage string provides the tools to
process the fast q files and transform
them into digital counts
you take the vast q files from your
lumia sequencer data run
and then we have an automated data
processing pipeline that then converts
them into these dcc files you then will
upload these dcc files into the genomics
platform and it will connect
the gene expression data back to each
specific region of interest
you can now build your analysis in dsp
in the dsp data analysis suite
on the left hand side we have the slide
explorer we can add in all the slides
from our study
this is a critical part of the platform
where you can
build these data analyses from multiple
sections and multiple slides
so you can build an analysis across
large cohorts of samples
from clinical trials data sets to
large internal studies
the software has all the tools to check
the quality of your data
normalize your reads and analyze the
data for interpretation
the middle section keeps track of any
changes you make to the data
and has a list of all the gene
annotations that we talked about
you can also visualize your data in
interesting and informative ways
importantly the software is interactive
and the genetic data is always tracked
back to the region
and of interest of the segment that
you're working with
so going back to our non-smell cell
along carcinoma samples
here we have these two region of
interest types
pl1 high and low regions in the tumor
the dsp data analysis we can analyze all
the similar regions and then compare the
expression
profiles between the two region types so
here we're looking at on the right is a
volcano plot
comparing the cd274 high and the two
cd 274 low regions
and you can get a list of all the
differentially expressed
genes between those two region types
this is just one
sample but you can expand this analysis
across
a large data set of samples
i would also encourage you to check out
our colorectal carcinoma whitening paper
that uses the cancer transcriptome atlas
to study the differences between um
two different main types of crc sample
types
one which is mss and one which is msi
these two different
clinical annotations have very different
outcomes and we use
three different profiling types to
analyze
these this this set of samples
we choose different region of interest
selection methods
um across multiple samples um
tantalize the immune system and how it's
changing both
across the individual samples and
between these
two different very different sample
types
so in review the cancer transcript
analyst
has an expansive collection of content
over 1800 genes across
95 annotated pathways it is very
comprehensive
um and includes targets in tumor biology
immune response and the microenvironment
it has critical gene signatures and you
can actually add in
targets of interest it has a minimal
sequencing requirement between 30 and 15
million reads per sample you can try it
now
in our technology access program and
it's going to ship
in august 2020. thank you for
joining this presentation
[Music]
thanks kid that's a really exciting new
product um wonderful presentation we
have
a number of questions for you now so um
the first is that
i work often with frozen tissue sections
can samples preserved in
oct be analyzed with the cta
you can use fresh frozen samples samples
that have been processed oct
on the gmx dsp platform we have a
protocol
for you to process your oct or fresh
frozen samples
to run on the genomics rna assay and the
cta
the second question relates to the
application of cta
to transplant biology how might that
the cancer transcriptome atlas be
applicable to other settings like that
we actually have quite a large number of
immune targets in the cancer
transcription atlas
these targets are spread across both
adaptive
and innate immunology and would be
applicable to any researcher who's doing
immunology related research
uh here's a third question for you kit i
work with very specific protease genes
for my research can i add them to the
cta
absolutely customers can add targets
on top of the cta for trans genes
or for genes that are not targeted in
the cta
that you can add up to 30 targets
to cta
okay we have another question here which
is my ngs core lab is in another
building how soon after i collect the
dsp barcodes
should i run the library prep
you can store the collection plate at
negative 20 for as long as you need to
and then you can thaw it and process the
library prep on
yourself or you can send it to your geo
genomics core
to do the library processing
and your final question kit which is i
just generated a single cell data set
with my samples can geomic spatial
profiling help me analyze my other data
sets
well that's a great question we're sure
that you're going to have other genomics
data sets that you're going to want to
integrate
into cta data i would actually encourage
you to check out a poster here in this
virtual
college conference from patrick danahar
that actually answers
this question
so i think we'd uh we'd all agree that
we've had a series of really wonderful
presentations today really exciting
science
and i want to um acknowledge and thank
all our speakers for participating
and sharing this really exciting data
with us
i think this is a very exciting and fast
moving field
the new technologies that are emerging
are i think you'll all agree
enabling us to answer questions that
were previously just intractable
and so i really look forward to some
wonderful new discoveries in this space
i want to also thank you for attending
and for making this conference
i want to acknowledge nanastring for
putting together this wonderful meeting
and i hope you can all tune in tomorrow
for the second day
in this virtual oncology conference
thank you